all right uh welcome to the ddpa seminar
everyone let's go over some logistics
first please mute yourself during the
talk unless you have questions if you
have questions you are welcome to unmute
and i ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q a session at the end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in in our youtube channel
uh that's about it now let me introduce
our speaker today
it is an honor to host christopher all
who is a faculty member in the graduate
fields of applied mathematics and
theoretical and applied mechanics and
civil and
environmental engineering at cornell
university um personally i i got the
the bachelor's degree
in civil and engineering at kona
university so i'm i'm very fond of that
place
and he is a professor in the center for
applied mathematics and the school of
civil and environmental engineering his
research in applied
mathematics has a focus on inverse
problems and scientific machine learning
he received his phd from the university
of minnesota twin
cities and his
master
masters and bachelor's degrees from
virginia tech
today chris will present an interesting
topic which is gaining mechanistic
insight through learning green's
functions uncovering the solutions to
hidden pdes please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk now without further ado
let me pass the button by
button to chris by
asking one random question as usual uh
since chris is from uh cornell ithaca
new york what is your favorite things to
do in itaka
ah uh running i really enjoy trail
running
oh my goodness yeah that's
it's it's wonderful place to run uh yeah
especially in the the campus at cornell
right yeah and
during the fall too it's lovely
yeah
yeah i remember okay it's all yours
uh thank you so much for that very kind
introduction yongsu it's uh it's great
to see uh one of our
former students
going on to do such wonderful things and
i deeply appreciate the uh invitation to
speak at the ddps seminar and i also
appreciate everyone listening and as
young 2 pointed out i'm going to be
discussing
[Music]
how it is you can learn
interesting things about your system
through the study of green's functions
that you uh uncover
and we're going to talk about different
ways that you might uncover these
screens functions
and so uh it's similar in in spirit to
sort of pde learning
and various people have have been
important on the pde learning front
hodlibsen at columbia university steve
brunton and nathan cuts at university of
washington
and hayden schaefer and other cornell
alumnus at carnegie mellon university
but rather than learning the partial
differential equation what we want to do
is learn linear
solution operators
compact integral functions integral
kernels that
that
give us
a different way to
study and
understand complex systems
and so other people have uh looked at um
learning green's functions in the past
notably uh lexington at uh in math
department stanford university uh
against steve brunton and uh
nathan cuts at university of washington
and their deep green paper and then also
some researchers and at caltech have
have some research on this idea of a
neural operator which is inspired by
green's functions um and that's kosher
andrew stewart and anima
kumar and uh but what i'm going to be
presenting today is is a different take
on on sort of even what what those folks
have been doing um rather than trying to
come up with sort of fast expressive
surrogates for partial differential
equations or solutions to partial
differential equations or
uh as stand-in forward models what we
want to do is
have the computer be our partner in
scientific discovery
exploiting or leveraging its pattern
recognition capabilities
as a means for understanding
complexities and subtleties in the
system by asking it to speak in a
language that we understand uh the
language of the universe or mathematics
and so um the talk is divided into three
parts today it starts from how physics
can inspire reduced order models and a
just-in-time physics modality
then that led to
some thinking about how it is we might
learn green's functions in a non-cyanl
context so this goes back to about 2012
before i was thinking about cyan l uh as
a as a uh interesting thing to pursue
and then uh the final third of the talk
will culminate in a uh
um a use of deep rational networks uh in
helping us to uh discover and understand
uh these uh solution operators uh or
green's functions that apply to some
hidden mechanism at work in a system
that we care about
and as with any research
i have a series of collaborators who i
have to acknowledge and thank and the
first part of the talk um related to
reduced order models um
this is conducted with a former phd
student of mine is now a postdoc at san
diego state university assilios fuentes
and then the second part of the talk
the empirical greens function work is
carried out with one of my doctoral
students at the center for applied
mathematics max jenkin and the very
talented harsh praveen a doctoral
student of mine at the school of civil
environmental engineering and then the
last third of the talk is a the newest
work and it's a collaboration between
uh a very talented doctoral student in
mathematics at oxford and nicolas lay
and my good friends in the math
department at cornell professor alex
townsend
and so as i indicated there are three
major
parts to this talk just enough physics
data driven reduced order modeling
piece and then how that inspired this
notion of learning what i call empirical
green's functions or green's functions
that
are distilled out of data that we see
streaming from the response of our
system
and then finally
how it is that we can extend this idea
of empirical green's functions to a much
broader context through the use of deep
learning and that will
then conclude this the talk today
and so um the original idea that i had
um for sort of data inspired reduced
order modeling came about as a result of
some work we're doing for the navy the
office of naval research and the top
side signatures program uh uh the
program officer for that is uh dr steven
russell
and um
in that program um there was a desire to
understand how it is that
electromagnetic radiation propagates and
the very complex environment that is the
lower troposphere of our atmosphere as
it impinges on the free surface of the
ocean
and so this um this lovely photograph of
this coastal setting uh i like to show
because it highlights some important
uh aspects of the complexities that
occur in this marine atmospheric
boundary layer or maple
so to start with we see that this is the
sun setting and normally we would expect
the sun to present itself as a
disk
and clearly
as a result of some interesting
atmospheric phenomenology the disc is no
longer a disc but has cusps and
discontinuities
and other interesting features
and furthermore we see that there is a
stratification in the coloring of the
sun if you notice this and these
features um are harbingers of things to
come uh in the next couple of slides so
i ask you just to remember these
features of stratification and
strangeness that occurs with respect to
the refractive index as a result of the
roiling mess that is the marine
atmospheric boundary layer there's you
know energy and mass fluxes between the
free surface of the ocean and the lower
atmosphere it's very very turbulent
complex
uh
medium to study
so the navy
was not interested in the optical uh
propagation properties and then mabel
but rather they were curious about the
performance of radar systems uh
specifically in the x-band of the
spectrum
and the x-band
is a
presents in a frequency range that
results in wavelengths uh of the em on
the order of ten centimeters or so
and so
you know normally we could um just
simply discretize our domain
and use
maxwell's lovely
system of partial differential equations
and
have that all that exquisite predictive
power that's encapsulated in those
simple expressions
uh to be able to make a propagation
prediction let's say in some in some
domain of interest but in the case of
the navy
uh application the domain of interest
was a box that was 100 meters by 50
kilometers and so uh the level of
discretization necessary for this domain
was
uh pretty ambitious
especially since the navy wanted a
faster than real-time solution and i'll
explain what i mean by faster faster
than real time later but it had to be
done extremely quickly and it just was
impractical to think that you could
solve a system that size a discretized
system this size and a faster than real
time context additionally
how is it that you could
sort of characterize all the subtle
features of uh refractivity changes um
point wise in a suitably discretized
domain okay so this is a challenging
forward problem
now
do it as an inverse problem so what you
want to do is then run that forward
query that forward solver as part of
some sort of
an optimization scheme to arrive at you
know a plausible solution to some
observations you're seeing on a
particular day and it becomes even more
difficult as you imagine running the
forward solver
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
maybe even millions of times
and so um as somebody who really didn't
know much about radar systems and had
only a an elementary level understanding
of electromagnetic propagation
i sort of
thought about this as saying you know
what if i didn't have an atmosphere i
would have a very simple case where a
receiver would inject electromagnetic
radiation into one end of my box it
would propagate down range and attenuate
itself with an inverse square law and at
a suitably long distance away from the
transmitter the receiver would
essentially see a plane wave
and so i asked the navy i said look what
is it you really care about what's your
quantity of interest and they said of
course we can't tell you but um how
about you play with this and they said
why don't you tell us how distorted a
wave would end up being downrange as a
result of the presence of the marine
atmospheric boundary layer
and so i had this thought that rather
than studying every bit of
subtlety at work
and the forward modeling of the problem
that you might carry along with the
maxwell solution
what if we just uh carried enough
physical insight uh to make a
a a
a rough model that gave us a
quantitative a quantity of interest a
prediction on a quantity of interest in
a way that was technologically useful
so motivated by that i was thinking that
this roiling nestled marine atmospheric
boundary layer could sort of be
integrated out
in the spirit of a blurring operator
like you might see in an imaging problem
and so the thought was maybe there's an
integral operator that can map the clean
image into the blurry image
and um
we could use this as a point of
departure additionally we also know from
experts domain experts that the marine
atmospheric boundary layer has this
stratified property there are these
layer wise structures that present
frequently in the
in in this region of the lower
atmosphere and so maybe we can exploit
that too
in our just enough physics
representation
so
again reminding ourselves or mentioning
again the idea of a blurring operator or
uh
sort of how it is that a point spread
function might be applied to a clean
image so let's say that this is the
clean image and this is a point spread
function like a gaussian blur or mofat
blur and then we integrate over the
clean image
with this blurring operator and end up
with some blurry image and that's what
you would do in a normal uh image
blurring problem but what now
if instead we said okay what if we took
the propagation
um
propagation factors in the downrange
setting that we measured okay the energy
deposited into the box and said that was
our without an atmosphere instead that
was our clean image and then the effect
of the marine atmospheric boundary layer
would be in some blurring operator such
that we would see what the receiver sees
on a particular day when an observation
is made
but now rather than having a small
support translation and variant kernel
operator like you would have for a point
spread
in an imaging problem i have my kernel
function supported over the entire
stratified domain of the marine
atmospheric boundary layer layer by
layer and so then the the kernel
function is expressing what the marine
atmospheric boundary layer does to a
vacuum propagation case and turns it
into something that looks real
and this is a freed home kernel and so
freedom integral theory says ah there's
a spectral decomposition of the kernel
function in terms of its uh complex the
complex conjugate of the eigenfunction
times the eigenfunction divided by the
eigenvalues
great but you can't go to the atmosphere
and say hey what are your eigenfunctions
and eigenvalues right that's just not
going to be a thing that uh
is uh feasible and so what if we replace
these orthonormal bases orthogonal bases
these eigenvases excuse me with data or
empirical
eigenbases or impuri uh empirical
eigenfunctions okay
pod modes
so if we sort of stare at the response
of our marine atmospheric boundary layer
in time
we can collect an ensemble of data from
which we can then extract pod modes
these modes then could be used to
approximate a blurring operator that uh
basically is a stand-in for what the
atmosphere is doing
furthermore we might have some salient
physical parameters that are um useful
in characterizing the environment we're
seeing ourself in on a particular day in
the maple it could be something like
relative humidity temperature barometric
pressure so it could be a vector
in any event we can then take these
orthonormal bases and place them onto
some
suitable manifold
and a non-linear context okay and um we
might have sort of a series of library
entries environments that we were able
to in our time
at leisure and in safety collect data at
okay particular theta values a nice data
one day i think a two day a theta three
day and so on and we have these bases
learned and we store them on a manifold
and then someday we find ourselves in a
dangerous situation where we have to
quickly figure out what kind of marine
atmospheric boundary layer do we have
today and i need to know fast
so then maybe we interpolate from the
ones we've seen
uh in nice times to
this place where we are during a
dangerous time and make an approximation
of how um the what the em weather is
like on that particular day
and so how would you collect data to
build these uh
empirical eigenfunctions so if we think
of
creating an ensemble on a theta one
weather day okay our mabel is in theta
one situation a theta two situation of
theta m situation then i could take
measurement realizations measurement one
measurement two measurement three
measurement four and one way to think
about this
would be that these measurements are
scintillations on variations on a theta
one theme
and a way to think about this is imagine
you're cooking out on your deck and
you're looking at your backyard so
there's the vista of your backyard okay
and your your grill is hot and you look
over your grill and sort of this the
buoyant uh buoyant
transfer of mass from the heated air up
into your field of view creates these
like heat waves i guess we call them
colloquially but they're density changes
that impact refractivity so you see sort
of this wavy image of your backyard
that's scintillation one another
realization would be scintillation two
scintillation three each of these are
analogous to the snapshot you might see
of your backyard which theta one you
look in a different direction and that
maybe is theta m okay so you have these
ensembles of data collected and you take
uh an svd
and you end up with a um
a uh
that didn't work sorry you end up with a
um
you end up with left singular vectors
that you can then use for your proper
orthogonal nodes
okay and so we see that
sort of down here
and this is a cartoon of the manifold
interpolation um so uh in in our case
we're using something called the compact
stifle manifold and we represent
our bases
for our library in blue and we lift
these to some flat space a tangent space
where we can do an interpolation and
restrict back down to
a point that we would like to know
something about a just-in-time basis
that would characterize our marine
atmospheric boundary layer and this idea
of manifold interpolation is not new uh
lots of people have used it before uh
charles farhad and
chris onslam wrote a paper a while back
an aia journal and before that there was
uh this is in the differential geometry
literature
and but the reason i'm showing the
algorithm here is just to point out to
you that this is a thin spd that gives
you the logarithmic lift to the tangent
space and the exponential restriction
back from the tangent space to the
complex default manifold is also
involving within svd this is very
efficient to calculate or compute using
modern numerical
libraries and so
it ends up being uh the solution that's
in this paper that we wrote in the ieee
transactions review and sciences are
about sensing
is a faster than real-time solution for
characterizing the marine atmospheric
boundary layer and faster than real-time
means our
characterization of the marine
atmospheric boundary layer is
carried out on a scale that's much
shorter
than the scale
by which the marine atmospheric boundary
layer evolves from state to state so we
characterize it more quickly
than the time necessary for it to change
to a new state and that's what that's
what the aim was
but
the reason i'm most excited about
sharing this with you is it kind of
inspired an idea in me i started looking
at the form of this equation and i
started thinking you know
this kind of reminds me of a greens
function if i put a source term here and
i have an impulse response then i can
get the solution to a partial
differential equation so if i can do
this as a just-in-time physics model
maybe i could learn the solution of a
hidden pde governing a system
for which i would like to know something
about
and so moving on to that setting
if we switch gears now and think about
some sort of a system a partial that's
described by a partial differential
equation
we have some linear differential
operator l
um acting on and and for the sake of
what i'm going to say now i'll just say
a scalar field to you
to produce a source term f
okay so generally speaking a greens
function is a classical solution where
you take the source term integrate
against this thing called a greens
function and you end up getting the
solution to the linear differential
operator for which g is a right inverse
okay and so this
g is essentially a linear point linear
impulse response function and so um you
can in some cases you can find these uh
through inspiration or through tricks
but other times they're hard to find and
so um it's kind of interesting to see if
you can learn these uh through data from
your system
and so also with this manifold
interpolation idea there's this
potential to extend the green's function
notion to non-linear regimes by
essentially sort of learning locally
linear patches on the riemannian
manifold and having a green's function
in the patch and then another patch and
another patch and sort of leap frogging
around the parameter space
of the uh of the solutions using uh
connections athene connections of a
certain type
leviticus connections
okay
so how would you do this so first of all
how would you collect data for a system
okay so let's say that there we
hypothesize that there's a partial
differential equation at work in our
system and we want to learn its solution
okay we don't want to learn its pde we
want to learn its solution operator
so it could be that we're stuck it could
be that we have to live with
whatever
the system is telling us so it could be
that we're just passively watching stuff
happen to the system
cause
going on to the system and the system
responding effect cause and effect data
from the system and maybe we have no
control over we just have to live with
whatever it gives us
okay in that restricted situation you
would not learn a good greens function
you would learn a restricted greens
function that corresponds to whatever
sub
subset of the
co image
for the linear differential operator
you're taking observations from
so you wouldn't be able to see the
entire greens function you'd only be
able to see a narrow piece of it because
that's all the system is being excited
to show you
so in the results i'm going to show
subsequently we actually excite our
system using random draws from a
gaussian process with us with a small
kernel function and that essentially
means that our source terms are like
wiggly spaghetti okay they have lots of
zero crossings and we we hit our system
with those the system responds and we
collect responses under these random
draws from some gaussian process they
think why the heck a gaussian process
and that's a fair question and i'm going
to ask you to please bear with me until
i get further into the talk and i'll
explain where that came from that idea
of using a gaussian process to excite
the system okay but
in any event we excite
we can ex if we can't control it we'll
take whatever excitation we can get
and watch a response if we can excite it
it would be great if we could excite
with something high frequency like
gaussian processes with small with that
with small with tight covariance kernels
um then if we assume that our linear
differential operator is self-adjoint
which is a very important assumption
okay then
our construction of the greens function
follows that same freedom spectral
decomposition that i used in the
just-in-time physics example and so this
is a serious limitation you know the pde
has to be self-adjoint for us to learn
in this way but a lot of important pdes
and the natural sciences are
self-adjoint and so it might be okay um
in the last third of the talk we'll
relax this requirement okay but for now
we need it to be
self-adjoint
and so in space the pod modes
are tracking the response the spatial
response and
what i'm showing in the subsequent
results are they're basically spatial
pdes if we needed to add the time
variable or space and time um one easy
way to do it would be to let the pod
modes still uh sort of
uh track the spatial response and then
let the coefficient
diagonal coefficient matrix sigma k
have a time dependence and so either at
every time step we fit a new sigma k or
in a slowly evolving system we might hit
epoch by epoch by epoch updating the
sigma k
and how do you update a sigma k and what
does that mean well
basically we have a loss function that
we want to satisfy and so what we have
are
observations from our system
and predictions
under our spectrally composed or
constructed greens function we know the
pod modes from the data what we don't
know are the coefficient the diagonal
coefficient matrices that give us a
suitable green's function approximation
so the way we arrive at this is by
argumenting a an average least squares
in an average least squares sense over
possible
diagonal coefficient matrices and once
we have a suitable error
tolerance achieved we call that our
z our our coefficient matrix okay that
corresponds to these pod modes to give
us a good approximation to a green's
function
and that's it okay so there's no machine
learning here it's just a simple data
driven
green empirical greens function
discovery process
but how well does it do
well if we do the hello world of pdes we
can look at poisson's equation with
homogeneous duration boundary conditions
and in this particular case we know the
green's function so we can sort of see
how well we do
and so the greens function we learn from
the data is shown on the left
for the poisson problem and then the
true greens function from the analytical
form is presented on the right and we
see that the relative error is somewhat
modest 0.01
and so
it seems pretty good for us
to our minds
but then this is noise free what if we
add some noise how well does it do and
so
we added what we thought was a lot of
noise so we took every sensor
measurement where a snapshot value was
collected
one each per column of our ensemble and
contaminated it with iid gaussian white
noise whose standard deviation was
the average response
of the entire data ensemble so it seems
like that's a pretty significant amount
of noise contamination and the error did
grow
between the the empirically discovered
and the ground truth uh to be three
times larger than it was before but
still the relative error is only 0.03 so
it's fairly modest again
okay what if we try helmholtz equation
um it's another pde where we have an
analytical form and so for this is the
square root of our eigenvalue uh for
hold step 15 on the on the unit interval
with dirichlet homogeneous boundary
conditions again
and we can compare to see how well our
constructed greens function or our
learned empirical greens function does
compared to the true green's function
and once again we see a modest relative
error at 0.03
and we can do this for aries equation
and 1d with theta equals 10. and in this
case we don't really have an analytical
form but this is what the method
uncovers and we see some very
interesting structures that are present
in the greens function besides the
anti-symmetry that's consistent with the
sulfa joint operator and so um i'll talk
more about what these symmetries might
mean later in the talk
but we could also
do let's say a multi-physics context
where we combine poisson and hemholtz
so one quarter of the domain is hemholtz
and the other three quarters are poisson
and
our snapshot then is a collection of
this multiphysics behavior and what then
would we learn and we we do see
structure in the learn greens function
uh that is indicative of a diffusion
operator and the top right
and something that is very reminiscent
of helmholtz in the bottom left and so
you know it it's interesting that you
know when you have multiple physical
dominant physical mechanisms at work
there is uh there is shadows of this
presence in the greens functions that
you learn uh with this method
we can also move to higher dimensions
instead of being on 1d this is the 2d
unit disc with uh for poisson
and we have again an exact greens
function for this case
and what you see are slices through the
learned empirical greens function versus
the analytical form
and a different slice through the
cross-section of the empirical green's
function
versus the
true ground truth case that's
analytically available to us
and
but then what about this idea of
interpolation
can we interpolate these empirical
greens functions to find green's
functions at places where we have no
data
so here is a aries equation in one d and
for the first aries equation we're
considering a theta value of one for the
secondaries equation we're considering a
theta value of five and the third
equation at theta value of ten what we
want to do is find the greens function
at a value theta value of 7
but not learned from data we want to put
it up on the manifold interpolate our
bases to the 7 location and reconstruct
the green's function there just in time
data free okay
and so we use manifold interpolation on
the pod modes and we use lagrangian
polynomials on the diagonal
coefficient matrices to perform the
linear interpolation there and so we see
that the character of the greens
functions at theta equals one theta
equals five and theta equals ten
are very different so our three library
entries that we're going to be
interpolating are each quite different
and so when we interpolate to this new
location 7
we see that our
learned empirical greens function
is very close to the target
green's function
when we when we actually learn it from
data okay so we we minimize our loss
function we gen we actually generate
data from the theta equals seven k so we
build a green's function so this is the
built greens function versus the
interpolated greens function and the
agreement between the two is uh 0.04 the
rel and relative error so we feel
that that's a reasonable um
reasonably good approximation for this
type of interpolation when you're not
using the data to build the use
but you're still restricted you're
limited to cases where you know you're a
self-adjoint partial differential
operator okay so what if we want to
relax that
so
this work is the work between nicolae
and alex townsend and i and um
it it this is now where we move into the
realm of scientific machine learning
okay so in this particular context we're
expressing our our solution
the scalar val this is you know we have
vector valued results i'll show you
later but this is a solution to some
linear partial differential operator and
we have our green's function being
integrated against a source term to
produce part of the solution and then we
have what we call the homogeneous
solution which is the effects of
boundary conditions other than
homogeneous dirichlet and
other types of interface conditions that
can be injected into the solution okay
so each one of these
the g
and the u homogeneous are their own
separate neural networks okay and i'll
explain more about this in a moment but
for now i want to tell you that we
excite our systems using draws from a
gaussian process okay a gp
and i told you i was going to tell you
why and so one of the reasons that we're
doing this is because nicola and alex
have a
a lovely theoretical paper uh
learning elliptic partial differential
equations with randomized linear algebra
is available on the archive
where they
guarantee that if you over sample
that you get a rank k approximation uh
almost surely uh
a best strength k approximation almost
surely if you over sample by some small
p as long as you're um
with high probability as long as your um
covariance kernel satisfies certain
requirements okay and so basically you
want the the spaghetti in your
calcium process to be very wiggly
and the more wiggly it is the fewer
training pairs you need
to be able to train the neural network
and the results i'm going to show
from here forward we're only using 100
training pairs uh to get these results
okay
and
so the gp motivation for the gpx
citations is in the paper by uh nikola
and alex and the other subtlety uh that
that's important to point out is that
the deep networks that we're learning to
uncover g the green's function and the
homogeneous solution they are what are
called rational neural networks and
these rational neural networks were
developed by nikola
and nakatsu casa and also townsend in
this paper rational neural networks
that's also available on the archive
it's the last entry on the bottom of
this slide
and these uh rational neural networks
are very very powerful and helpful to us
as we try to glean physical insight into
what's going on mechanistically within
our system and i'll show why in a minute
but essentially what's happening is the
activation functions in the neural
network typically like relu hyperbolic
tangent
we're replacing those by three two
rational functions okay and it's a
constant rational function per hidden uh
layer okay so every hidden unit in the
hidden layer uses the same 3-2 rational
activation function so it doesn't add a
lot of free parameters to the model
okay so as a cartoon here's what we're
doing
in this uh most generalized example of
learning green's functions we take a
carefully constructed covariance kernel
and we
take random draws
random spaghetti out of the gaussian
process we use these random draws as
excitations on some unknown system and
we watch how the system behaves under
these random draws
these this collection of cause and
effect data then are the training data
that we use to train two
rational deep neural networks one for
the greens function and one for the
homogeneous solution
these
both are trained off of the same loss
function inspired by this equation which
is the solution is the superposition of
the homogeneous and the green's function
integration so we have a superposition
of the homogeneous and the greens
function
integration
compared with
the response solution and normalized
okay
at the end of this the networks contain
greens functions and homogeneous
solutions respectively and then we
extract those into a visual
form that we can interpret as human
beings okay and this is a semantically
rich form for us and it it it's a it's a
it's an abstract mathematical quantity
that has deep meaning to us and we can
study things about
what we're seeing
specifically if we have now the greens
function and the homogeneous solution we
can look for
symmetries
conservations
in variance that all are present in the
greens function that tell us important
things about the linear differential
operators that then also tells us
something mechanistically important
about the physical system
partial differential equations are the
language of our natural world if we
understand things about the solutions to
these partial differential equations we
understand something about what's going
on in that system so there's a there's a
hint of mechanism in things that we're
seeing in the solutions that we're
learning
we also have the opportunity to watch
how it is the eigenvalues decay
within our solutions and also what the
dominant eigen modes of the green's
function
solutions are
furthermore the use of the rational
neural networks gives us yet another
tool for physical insight
when we look at the clustering of the
poles of the rational approximant
they tend to cluster at locations of
singularity in the actual pro the actual
function that is being approximated so
the solution to the pde
um is have may have a singularity in it
and the rational poles will cluster at
the location of that singularity giving
us and we can study the nature of that
singularity
okay so how well does this work so
here's the the classic self-adjoint case
that i've been showing you so this is
the exact analytical form of the greens
function for the 1d plus song case and
here's the reproduction using the deep
neural network okay it looks great so
what we've already done this okay so now
we're going to a non-sulfa joint case
and so here we see advection diffusion
and in the advection diffusion case we
have an analytic greens function and a
learned green's function and we see that
the deep rational neural network is able
to do a very good job to the eyeball
norm at reconstructing this the screens
function
and we can do this in two dimensions as
well so here's the exact on the 2d
disc unit disc for poisson's equation
here's the exact greens function two
slices
and here's the learned greens function
for those same slices there's a little
bit of noise in this in these
reconstructions because our grid was
fairly coarse and this was as a result
of some computational issues that we
were having in terms of not having
access to a powerful enough computer at
that moment
another interesting example would be
what i want to call your attention to on
this top line this top line is an
advection diffusion 1d induction
diffusion problem whose coefficient
functions are such that a viscous shock
forms
at the mid
mid domain of the problem okay and so
when we learn the green's function with
this problem we see that there is a
concentration of energy sort of at the
mid point of the domain and we have uh
reflexive symmetry across the green's
function
i additionally the homogeneous solution
clearly shows the step function
property of the shock
and
when we look at the phase portrait of
the rational neural networks we see the
poles of the rational functions
clustering right to the real line at the
exact location where the um
where the
singularity is and the solution okay
so how robust is this approach when we
don't have a lot of data how robust is
it to data sparsity so let's be
diabolical let's put two black lines in
our domain
and exclude
any data
from in and around the shock
front and this uh in this advection
diffusion problem okay and only learn
the stuff outside the shock front
and if we do that the greens function we
recover is a very good approximation to
the true greens function reflexive
symmetry is still present there is a
concentration of energy in the shock
region
and we also see that the homogeneous
solution is able to recreate the
step-wise properties of of the
discontinuity
and still the rational poles cluster to
the real line at the location of the
singularity in the problem of interest
and then the last one is sort of this
multiphysics context where we have
diffusion in one portion of the domain
and advection in the other portion of
the domain and we clearly see um the the
greens function of the diffusion
operator self-adjoint and the
non-self-adjoint advection operator
presenting themselves quite clearly to
the eye
and the greens function the homogeneous
solution agrees well and the rational
poles converge to the real line at the
location of the transition in the
physics and so that's also a helpful
clue as to something interesting going
on in the problem
and we can even sort of tackle weekly
non-linear cases so what we have here
is the helmholtz sturm libel and
bioharmonic operators which are
themselves linear but we add to them
a
a semi-linear
we make them semi-linear in that the
leading the the higher order highest
order derivative the leading term and
the partial differential equation is
still linear but the tr the lower order
terms are non-linear and in this case
they're cubically non-linear uh with an
epsilon parameter where epsilon is a
value between zero and one so some
people would call this weekly non-linear
some people call this semi-linear um
it's non-linear but not really really
non-linear if that's uh precise enough
for you
that's how i like to think of it and so
what you end up doing is you end up
learning sort of a locally linear
approximation to
hemholtz thermolivable and by harmonic
in their semi-linear states okay we
believe that this is important so you
can get some mechanistic insight from
what it is that's going on in your
system at a certain uh parameter value
by looking at this locally linear
representation
and then lastly i wanted to mention that
we can tackle systems
so here we have um a stokes flow example
so stokes flow is a system of partial
differential equations velocity and
pressure
coupled so this is
an incompressible newtonian context
where there's a no slip boundary on
these three walls where my cursor is
tracing out and a constant velocity
field across the top some people call
this the lid driven cavity benchmark
problem and cfd codes okay and the exact
velocity versus a learned velocity is a
good agreement the learned velocity is
what we get from running our learned
greens function
against the source terms and we get a
excellent fidelity to the exact solution
but what is most interesting
for our purposes is this block matrix of
green's functions so we have sort of
these dominant
diagonal terms uh and these cross terms
which represent the coupling and so we
can tackle systems of partial
differential equations
the result of which is
sort of a block matrix of of green's
functions themselves
and another way to sort of see this more
clearly
is with ordinary linear differential
operators so we have here two second
order odes that are coupled
with uh sort of uh since some simple
little boundary conditions
and we can then learn the greens
functions for these guys and what we see
is we see the nice diffusion operation
uh diffusion solution that's occurring
on the one one and the two two block and
the cross blocks are the coupling
effects and uh the homogeneous solutions
for the two cases are also reproduced
here
okay so
systems are also possible
with this deep learning approach using
rational neural networks
and so um
there's a lot of examples that i didn't
have time to talk about and they're
available in our paper on the archive
it's data-driven discovery of physical
laws with human understandable deep
learning um and so i invite you to look
at that if you're interested um
additionally if you want to see even
more examples that are in the paper you
can visit greenlearning.readthedocs.io
and if you'd like to try out some of
these techniques
they're very easy to use truthfully
if you'd like to try some of these out
yourself it's written or you can visit
nicolas github repo under uh green
learning and you'll see uh sort of
python code and uh the ml implementation
is in tensorflow so if you're
comfortable with tensorflow that's how
it's currently set up
so i would invite you to
play around with those
and um
you know as a final thought i guess i
would just say that
i really believe that there's a lot of
opportunity for a partnership to emerge
between uh sort of computers with
machine learning algorithms running on
them and us as scientists trying to
understand our natural and technological
world i feel like the computers have
this very important capability of
untangling
divining untangling things dividing out
subtle patterns and seeing things that
are hard for us to see but at the same
time we need to make them speak our
language and
and it's not just our language it's the
language that
seems to permeate the universe the
language of math and not just ones and
zeros in addition and subtraction but
complex math fire map so
having the computers be able to
beat us having there to be a partnership
with the computers seems to be a very
fruitful direction to move in as we push
the frontiers of scientific inquiry and
so we're very passionate about that in
my group and
and hope to continue working on this for
quite some time
and with that i would just say thank you
very much for your attention and um if
you have any questions i'm happy to try
to answer them now or you can if you
think of them later please feel free to
email me but thank you so much for your
attention
thank you thank you so much for the
great talk
thumbs up
really really great talk i loved it um
let's have
a q a session um oh wow great um
rob
has asked what ended up happening with
the
radar project
ah so um we continued the radar project
continued for quite a while uh
over many years and we we we started
with this faster than real-time
sort of just-in-time physics idea then
we moved to a normal mode approximation
idea and then we moved to a
a couple of different machine learning
approaches with deep networks and
convolutional neural networks and so we
we pursued many different flavors of
faster than real-time inversion schemes
and um
i honestly so now we're done
so we i think we had four projects uh
doing different things and um i i don't
know exactly if anything is being used
uh
you know it's tough to know right
because uh this this is a
they they sort of give you you know you
give you're given a problem
that is kind of vanilla and generic
and then you do your thing and you
publish your results and maybe someone's
using it behind the scenes and you just
don't know about it so i i hope
somebody's using it so i feel better
about
doing the work but it could be that no
one is using it certainly there are some
papers about it and if you visit our
website you can find those papers if
you're interested
okay sounds good um
charlie asked is the shock
formation example you showed similar to
self-supervised learning
not really because you have training
data right so it's uh unless i'm
misunderstanding about uh what you mean
by self-supervised learning but i feel i
we definitely have training oh you mean
with the data missing
that people
yeah he said yes uh yes the data missing
because sorry
yeah i was i'm really surprised that he
was able to pick up the shock so well
we were too
yeah and so i thought you have so little
data
right to infer from it and how does it
know
where to put the the the discontinuity
right that's
yeah yeah no i think i think a lot of
this uh and i can't recall if nicole i
think nicole is on the on the uh in the
meeting and he can correct me if i'm
wrong
i believe it has to do with the really
powerful approximating capabilities of
the rational neural network so there's
enough of a shadow
of this signal
from the shock
in the areas where the you know the side
measurements were made
that it was
able to fit a rational function through
that and i don't know nicola are you
still out there
yeah yeah yeah i think it's yeah it's
correct it's because it has good
approximation outside of this missing
data it's kind of fun
a good interpolant bit in between that
is like kind of the most simple way to
interpolate between these points
okay
thank you thank you thank you thanks
nicola
that sounds like rational neural network
is pretty powerful
makes me curious about that yeah yeah
good paper
all right next question is um
again by rob
he asked what networks approaches did
you try
that didn't work at all
uh what what neural network approaches i
i think so
ah
so
that
i
don't
have an answer to i i i believe we just
started with rational networks we in the
paper we tried relu and we tried other
activation functions
but we generally what we were
how should we say encouraged by was
we used the same
four layer 50 for hidden layer 50 hidden
unit network across all examples and
never had
we just ran basically randomly selected
it and never adjusted it and it just
always worked
and so um that was one of the other
things we found very startling about
this approach was how robust it was to
the architecture itself
we never played with the architecture
we just used the same thing every time
and
and that these are the results and so
there was no uh cherry picking uh no
games played it was just
yeah i've been drawing and that's what
it was yeah it looks like uh rob has his
personal experience with a rational
network and he
um whenever he uses the
ingredient descent
it it fails um
to result
near the singularity
i guess rob you can add more details
about your plastic experience
if you are connected connected to the
sounds maybe
nicola do you have any thoughts on that
that to me that doesn't sound like
anything we experienced do you remember
seeing anything like that
uh it may be because in the paper we
used a second order optimizer as well
which is uh takes advantage of the
smoothness of fashion on your network to
do the optimization so it is able to
converge to a much better local minima
than uh quadrant descent
oh so yeah we we
thanks nicole so we're combining adam
with lb
ldfgs
uh and during the optimization scheme
okay well i i hope robin you guys can be
reconnected
after this talk and that sounds great
yeah yeah yeah that's that would be
wonderful
uh i have a question another question
sorry uh okay go ahead yeah what's up i
mean this is fantastic it's really great
work and i'm just kind of wondering
what's the next steps for moving forward
with this you know with this
new tool and
how do you plan to scale this up
for regular well for that i have i have
suggestions actually um how about the
shredding freezinger uh equations that's
that is a linear
and
i'm not sure
how
you know the greens functions is the
analytic rings function is available or
maybe we can
automatically
yeah
in the supplemental material uh for the
paper out on archive we do do
schroedinger's equation
yeah and so there's a there's an example
that i would invite you to take a peek
at
but maybe in answering charlie's
question i would say that currently what
we're doing um
is to try to see if we can learn
something new about real from real
systems and so we're we're looking at uh
collaborators uh both on the biosciences
and also um well basically in life
sciences and biosciences we're looking
at applications that are related to the
flight of birds and also um the
metabolic behaviors of
microbes and so we just kind of want to
see if we can actually
learn something new for a change like we
we rediscovered we rediscovered
solutions to pdes where we discovered
solutions that didn't previously know
about two pdes but what if we try it
with system data actual system data what
could we what could we find out and so
that's kind of where we're moving it in
in this at this juncture
okay thank you so much
it's good yes
another another suggestion suggestions
for the the future work um
is investigating the scalability of of
your methods so that it can be
applicable to larger scale problems
usually um
you know
from the perspective of national lab
what we are usually dealing with is a
huge problem um
so
you know using hpc and you know making
the algorithm scalable that's kind of
one of the big issue
here so it's fantastic it's fantastic
that your
your um
your work is working really well uh but
um you know
for the future uh directions it might be
really even more fantastic if we can
make it scalable so that
we can apply that to larger scale
problem any comments on that chris
uh i think you know we
nikola
we we bumped into some uh scalability
issues when we were looking at systems
and it was primarily related to uh
gpus and uh what kinds of systems we had
and we really didn't try
to access uh we had very modest systems
and we were able to do you know things
like you saw with the
lid driven cavity and so forth but if
you want to do
um you know much much bigger systems
there's you know access to gpu computing
is a must
to be able to tackle bigger problems and
i think that's a common
uh
problem with with most with most
machine learning problems these days
the issue you know the question also is
how scalable is sort of these
off-the-shelf
uh tensorflow and torch libraries you
know are they
truly the state-of-the-art are they open
source insured because they're kind of
fun to use but they're like you know
google and facebook have their own stuff
you know hidden away that's even more
efficient i don't know um but that's a
certainly a question that goes into the
uh
you know obviously you know deep mind is
doing things with protein folding and
you know
what are they using to do these enormous
machine learning runs and how are those
scaling um you know that i i don't know
if they're using straight tensorflow or
not or how they're doing it
so i'm not sure that i can answer this
question beyond saying that i think
you need to deploy like if we were just
to use the libraries that we have now
and deploy them on gpus we could tackle
much much bigger problems but you know
how scalable are they i really couldn't
say at this point um nicola is the uh
the man with the plan when it comes to
the implementation so maybe he can uh
add something that i'm missing nicola is
that true
yeah it's already running on gpus but we
don't have large
access to gpus but the the method itself
uh should support uh things like domain
decomposition and all sort of
optimization we could do to scale a
problem we could easily do them in the
composition later
nice nice um i mean
lotus livermore we do have a
huge gpu machine so
let's
probably you know future collaboration
would be wonderful that would be
fantastic very happy to explore that all
right sounds good
okay any other questions from audiences
no okay so well then with that uh let's
thank um the chris
uh for the wonderful talk again and also
his students nicola to answering the
questions and thank you so much for the
wonderful talk and um i hope this you
know the seminar talk uh is becoming a
first
the breach
you know for the future collaboration
between you know a lot of external
forces and lauren's for more foxes with
you your the research team chris um that
would be wonderful i'd be very happy to
explore anything like that that would be
great again soon
thank you thank you all right thank you
so much again
thank you
okay bye bye